they can endure the cold reaches of
space
go without food or water for up to
30 years and are nearly
indestructible but they're like
really tiny so there's not a whole lot
we can do with them
however what if tardigrades
were the size of humans how could we use
them
would we live in harmony or are we no
longer at the top of the food chain
this is what f and here's what would
happen
if tardigrades were the size of humans
this is a tardigrade you can call me
tardy but i'm always on time
yeah kind of looks like an eight-legged
bear doesn't it
well an eight-legged bear from your
nightmares is more accurate
while only measuring in at 1.2
millimeters
max these guys are as tough as nails
tardigrades are classified as
extremophiles
this means that they can roll with the
punches in whatever
extreme environment they call home they
can go
30 years without food or water thrive in
an
absolute zero or above boiling
temperature
and survive in pressures six times that
of our ocean's deepest trenches
these teeny tanks can thank a unique
protein for their resiliency known as
dsop which is short for damage
suppressor
so what would life be like if
tardigrades
had a growth spurt well picture this
you've got a nice little pond in your
backyard it's quaint
relaxing and really brings the whole
yard together well
freshwater sediments like your pond may
have
as many as 25 000 tardigrades per liter
or almost 000 of them per gallon
but now things aren't as cozy imagine
taking a look out your window and seeing
25 000 human-sized tardigrades
dog-piled in your backyard our planet
would be swamped with giant tardigrades
okay there's gotta be a plus side to
this maybe we could use them for
something
what if you rounded up a posse and went
hunting for tardigrade
could we use their hard outer hides to
create
protective wear and get some of that
sweet sweet decep for ourselves
tardigrades are encased in a rugged
flexible
cuticle imagine a cow with
armor similar to the exoskeletons of
grasshoppers
maybe the military could use this
pliable yet sturdy material for some
heavy-duty tardigrade armor
now those are some cool ideas but
remember what i said about them being
extremophiles
yeah they're not going down that easy
they
don't even care about things that would
give humans a run for their money
take droughts for example a dry
environment
might trigger a tardigrade to go into a
cryptobiosis state
the tardigrade will squeeze all the
water out of its body
retract its head and limbs and roll up
into a little ball
and become dormant this is known as a
ton
when in this form the tardigrade's
metabolism
slows to 0.01 percent
of the normal rate and it can maintain
this halted state for
decades until it again comes into
contact with water
hey cut it out so now that they're
asleep you might be thinking it's the
perfect time to attack
well we wouldn't recommend it
a giant angry tardigrade has eight legs
and
four to six claws on each paw not to
mention their dagger-like teeth that
also make them ferocious killers
now thankfully we don't have to worry
about our planet being overrun by
human-sized tardigrades but
that doesn't mean we can't still learn
from them
because they are so resilient we could
gain a thing or two from these tiny
titans
such as how to develop more resilient
crops by
using their valuable dsup protein
i guess we could count ourselves lucky
that if tardigrades were the size of
humans
they'd be like big lumbering cows
so at least they wouldn't be flying
around us dive-bombing our heads
did you hear that kind of sounds like a
bat
what if bats were the size of humans
well
that's a story for another what if